[Music]
all right and we are laughs are and all
with the Lord y'all getting there no
intro right now hope y'all like it check
it out
no revamp you don't stand round table
reviews fresh out of Joker we got my man
Chi by two special guests Lord meds you
know first time in the building with the
Lord's you know so you know we just came
out of Joker these are war reactions
everybody has a lot to say you know we
gonna set it off with sovereign Lord
Soph you just finished seeing a very
powerful piece so uh what do you think
man what is your impressions of Joker so
just you guys know it's full spoilers
this full spoiler so when we post it up
we'll let you guys know this is full
spoilers for this movie I have to say as
a lifelong Batman fan and particularly
of the Joker because the Joker for me
has always been the perfect antithesis
to Batman he is the reason in a lot of
way in a lot of ways why Batman sort of
is and vice-versa
Batman sort of is defined by his
obsession with the Joker I thought this
was an amazing performance and look into
how one person can possibly go from
being someone who is mentally ill and
feeling that he's been sort of kicked to
the side by society and then just in a
roundabout way find sort of his place in
the world by literally stepping into
madness
and and and realizing and understanding
that what other people deemed to be
horrible is his happy place it was a
fantastic performance by Joaquin Phoenix
I have to say like as an origin it is up
there with anything I've ever seen
Batman Begins like we'll talk about how
I compare it to other ones and because
it's that there's specific things about
it that I don't think it's this movie's
fault or every color of its of origin
story or it has anything to do with
Joaquin Phoenix but there are reasons
that I feel may be certain of the
performance a certain other performance
encompasses the Batman feel more but
beyond that this it was amazing got lost
so afro yo we gotta get meds in the bill
we got special guest in the building you
know saying shout out shout to the to
the Bronx scenery we felt we saw beds
yo I'm gonna give it to Lord man's man
Rory actually you were right next to me
watching this thing I was seeing your
face we was we was vibing what's the
word man what's the energy on Joker ah
okay so I'm gonna be coming with a lot
of hyperbole here because I just saw the
movie we're literally in the theaters
and the seats we were sitting in best
origin story I've ever seen right
possibly the best performance of any
actor I've seen in any comic book based
movie period straight up I think he's
surpassed Heath I gotta say I think he's
surpassed Eve it was a different style
it was different style not necessarily
exactly you know what he did great was
that he didn't try to do Heath he did
his own thing and I thought it was
beautiful and perfect um and the Bronx
scenery that I don't care if they told
me that this movie was filmed in DC that
was the Bronx okay the crime of an 80s
New York City was perfectly perfectly
realized like that was 80s New York City
grimy dirty you even see the little
things you hold on to on the train that
they don't have those anymore
yes yes so so yeah before I pass it off
to you guys fantastic film recommended
towards everybody maybe I'm a little
crazy because when he started killing
people I was laughing like I was loving
it I was squirming in my CS he was
sitting right next to me kognito I was
squirming smiling laughing that was the
best part the violence was like no and
one last thing I love how he definitely
killed some people
and they didn't even show it like it was
implied that he killed them which was
beautiful like the the lady that he
seemed like he was dating but they
weren't dating at all it was all in his
head he definitely killed her killed her
daughter killed that doctor at the end
yo an incredible incredible movie they
already got me soaked eyebots
you know we have some maybe different
opinions of the vibe I'm getting from
you when I was watching your reactions a
little different so I gotta hear from
the dork I bots ooh man wait you out
with this thing well yeah I was joking
well the one thing I definitely have to
say about the movie is that it is one of
the greatest tour-de-force movies I've
actually seen that I'll probably never
want to see again it's just um when you
go to the life of seeing our artifact of
what he's going through is you could see
that he doesn't have much in life he's
gone through a lot of hardships and just
for the sake of his his mother who told
him one time that like you're born to
make people laugh you're born to make
people happy but as you're going through
the actual movie and seeing everything
that he goes through from his work to
the way that he interacts with people
and plus also the condition that he
deals with it's like the movie tries to
play is like that he tries to that he's
trying to just live within within the
life as a joke but then is like as you
go through the movie and you see
everything that he's going through
you realize this Joker comes about
because life is a sick joke and he
becomes the Joker to actually control
the
heritage and the thing about it is that
when you're watching the movie it's like
watching a loaded gun pool you're
waiting to see when he snaps something
else happens like he gets a tag he gets
attacked he loses his job and it goes
into the foundation of the Joker in the
comics which is one very bad day
exhausted him to do this if oh oh that
was I was fired here's the thing man I
mean I'll be honest with you guys like I
didn't know what to expect coming into
this film I perfect perfect purposely
stayed away from more spoilers I just
saw a reaction from people I trust and
it was to the point where people were
like yo this is a very powerful movie
this is a must see so coming into it I
kept my expectations in check I have to
admit just to beat the setting grimy you
know Gotham aka the Bronx between oh go
ahead innocent but you know at the end
of the day it was just like seeing his
life seeing everything that this man is
going through he did become a
sympathetic figure and and the thing
that really hit home for me was I know
me and Max we're talking about it didn't
thing his depiction of mental illness I
think was done so well because there
were times when I'm like oh he's dating
that chick or I'm like yo I need to
start stalking chicks because all I
gotta do is is pull up and smile and I
can get the joint you know so I have to
kind of throw my head oh yeah like the
stalk of drink no actually from the way
the interaction that was going on with
the love interest as he beats is that
you could tell because he was doing way
too many things that any normal prefer
any normal person would I saw a scene as
red flags right so you could probably
already tell what the twist was there
but I just felt it was shot so well that
it had me fooled because Gotham is so
effed up did I figure you know she's
like alright this crazy guy down the
hall that I think is cute is stalking me
okay like she enjoyed that dad no but
that was the flip that even though this
was going on in his mind which was shot
so
there was a little pinch of meat I said
well maybe you know this is real it was
going on it was done in such a way that
you could possibly think it could happen
even though part of me was like nah
family he's a little wild you should see
some red flags not to be messing with
this dude but then as it progresses and
unders layest comes off in his insanity
deepens and it gets crazy with the with
the illness and you start to see the
layers film away and it's like no this
is in his mind he's really gone and it
was just so well done man I just think
right now we're gonna get into my next
rank which is comparisons and all that
but I think right now it far as origin
is concerned explaining why he is the
way is it I know cuz Sauer feels a
little differently about what I'm about
to say but I thought it was so normal II
I don't care about why the villain is
the way he is joke is a very intriguing
character and I definitely think that
this was done in such a way that I
understand it I'm like and I did him as
the rallying call for all these people
because let's be real it was like almost
a societal thing like the rich versus
the poor the whole and then we got we
got to talk about the Batman tie-ins now
it's fire so saw him get back so
specifically about the Batman tie-ins
well every I mean honestly performances
across the board the movie to me was so
well acted it was again in a lot of ways
it didn't need to be a Joker movie this
was a movie about anybody having anybody
finding out that everything in their
life has been a lie and then how you how
do you react to that and how do you
react had in the context of the world
that you live in and I think his
reaction crazy as it may be wasn't
necessarily out of line with the world
that they showed us so I thought that
was fantastic the small little nuts
about obviously the Thomas Wayne
connection and and the sort of the the
how they fooled us into thinking that he
was he was related to Thomas Wayne your
I thought they was gonna flip it like
like he Joker was a jump-off like was a
junk off baby
like don't Frank III was like oh Thomas
Wayne was out here freakin he was they
actually brothers I mean to me that was
if they had really gone that route that
would have been kind of nuts that would
have been but again they they teased it
and it isn't not like that um obviously
little cool things I don't know if you
guys noticed when he went to the Wayne -
Wayne Manor and Bruce was young Bruce
was on the like on the monkey bars or
whatever he slides down the pole little
things like that um so the fact that
they do begin to tie it into Batman is
what I enjoy right because you would
hope yeah I don't think walking Phoenix
is not type of actor to do it to do
multiple movies in same character that's
not him um but I would love to see his
Joker versus a Batman in that world I
don't know that we'll ever see it but
that's fine um so then going into why
we're gonna start now let's get into the
comparisons between him and the goat -
now obviously Heath Ledger um they're
they're two things that don't have for
me these are personal things for me when
it comes to the performance although
they did specifically start to talk
about these connections with the Wayne
family and Bruce and and Batman or
whatever obviously has an origin story
you don't get into the how deep that
that goes and modern Joker is very much
defined by his obsession with Batman and
the fact that Batman won't be can't
break Batman right and Batman's
obsession as well as defined at
especially in the modern time by how far
Joker pushes him and the fact that he
the line continues to move a little bit
when he has to deal with Joker because
he understands that it's the immovable
force versus that versus versus whatever
objects right so that obviously isn't
conveyed in this movie because it's an
origin story so that's not the fault of
that now my other issue and that this is
a personal thing for me
I love seeing origins when it when it
comes to a hero I like to see how a hero
rises up love to see villains - but when
it comes to the archetypical prime
villain
there's something to be said for not
knowing where the
there came from right when you're
compared to horror movies what they've
recently done with Michael Myers and try
to give context for why Michael Myers is
a psychopathic killer I think it
diminishes the character because he's
just not he's just not a killer for the
sake of killing right you understand
where he comes from and in a certain
timeline right and I think that for me
part of the what makes the Joker so
amazing is the fact that he you don't
know you just don't know what brought
him to this point ruin it for me but it
takes some of that mystique away from
the fact that that he's just evil for
the sake of evil he's crazy for the sake
of crazy and he's become obsessed with
this with this figure that's just as
crazy as him but on the other side of
the coin and I just don't think and I
think once you give context for how he
got there it diminishes that a little
bit doesn't diminish the performance
doesn't diminish the origin but as as
just talking about it Batman's primary
villain I was okay with not necessarily
knowing exactly exactly one thing I
definitely want to say about it also
first of all I'm kind of disappointed
that you guys actually thought that
relationship was real that was like
there was a so many red flags like hey
that's what you stalking me well but
when it came to what you said that you
were kind of disappointing and learning
is the origins yeah if you think about
everything that actually went into the
movie how do you know that any of it is
ooh is even real and it goes into one of
the things that I liked about the movie
and about Joker's main origin that Joker
Joker even said it himself he said I
prefer my origins to be multiple choice
so and the thing is there were so many
things in the movie at first it was
something that worked me but
as I watched it I realized there was a
lot of situations where like they were
deus ex machina where they fit perfectly
into showing him as a hero right like
I'll give you one example
especially on with the talk show host
murder murray robot away yeah robert de
niro did an outstanding job the one
thing that kind of caught me off guard
is that after he confessed his crimes he
let him talk for like a good 15 20
minutes in the chair and nobody was
calling the cops and stuff like that
there was a lot of instances in the
movie where that happened where it
seemed like everything was perfectly fit
to show all to show to show his point of
views which is why i like it kind of
irks me as a movie because it seems that
this point they should shut them down
and this should have been yeah and
especially like the whole situation is
like hey yeah you stalk me let me let me
take you on a date but also I mean as a
one time went on I kind of preciate
about the movie because like I said the
foundation of Joker is is subversion he
doesn't want you to think exactly what
you wanted to think he wants to give you
so many options that you really don't
know what's going on and that movie the
movie has that in spades enough I won't
get mad mentally I need some more
context and performance brother okay so
obviously to Joaquin Phoenix fantastic
Robert DeNiro killed that this movie and
yeah Robert De Niro's been in several
stinkers as of late so you know shout
out to him a little brief cameo by my
boy brain Kyle and Bryan Callen shout
out to him
the woman was her name desi beats fat
and quit yeah yeah yeah I shouted out to
him out yeah incredible the way that
they shot the city to me just like you
guys said gritty eighties New York City
like dirty like the New York City didn't
look the way it looks now back then it
was grimy and dirty and crappy and you
know back to what you guys were saying
about the origin story and how it's
subjective and perhaps even
multiple-choice you know it cuts back at
the end to him talking to that doctor
who we ended up Merkin
who's to say that was Justin just him
making up the whole movie was just him
making up that story to that doctor sort
of I thought it might be like the the
twist at the end of the movie was that
that walking Phoenix isn't him in the
Joker right and the actual Joker is
telling this version of his of his
origin to this doctor right so it's very
much a story that he told and he
embellished in a lot of ways absolutely
it look it looked that way to me as well
and I like the fact that they told the
origin story and I know you like the
ambiguity but I loved it I loved it
well that's that's my thoughts shout-out
to send us in a synopsis for letting us
record this after the movie give it back
to cog they good bye to kick us out you
only Arnaud's almost expired but up
listen man you know fantastic film I
think all you guys make great points I
think the main thing that came away from
me is again just the understanding of
mental illness and his I think again not
just a sympathetic figure but I also
felt they portrayed well one of my
biggest things with watching Joker and
stuff in the comics right I always say
this man is insane right how could he
get any bit of a following and I think
this was the first time I understood why
people would follow him and yeah because
you watch every Batman movie and
everything that you know a whole bunch
of clowns around I'm like realistically
gonna follow this dude but I think this
was the first time that the war was
cracked and I'm like yo you know I'm
saying and again just the whole thing
the the tragedy so to speak with the
mother and and everything and finding
out your reality of what it is and then
even that horrific scene ah I want to
get to the controversies real quickly is
that I've seen some comments and people
be like yo this is not a movie to see if
people like people are trash in this
movie and I'm saying some people all I
would say is that in context with this
character this in my opinion is
beautifully done in context with what's
going on if you want to take this and
you know watch this and do something
else on your own that's your own
business you know them all I'm saying is
in pertain to the source material the
it fit and it's a great interpretation
as to why he could possibly be that way
that's all I'm getting out of it but
that's what I got me anyone else another
Louis got anything else before we wrap
up any little final thoughts look man
are not like the Lord's we vant Reloaded
lower beds in the building Lord saw if
you already know we can be trying to do
this at least once a month and get back
and like I said please give us your
feedback let us know what's going on
you already know Sunday is the Lord's
Day 11:00 a.m. Eastern NFL say anytime
yeah anything else King no give me the
means tomorrow King my baked eyeshadows
before you get out we've been doing this
for what is about two three years thanks
to all you guys the viewers and again
even though that this is hard work for
each of us do every single day we
appreciate all of you and just keep up
with us because there's gonna be more
bigger things coming down the line you
already know man R&R with the Lord's
catch us again hopefully the next big
film and after that that's it man so
everybody enjoy your Sunday and all that
good stuff we'll catch you please
[Music]